five in the morning the liking has
arrived da da ba da da
alright let's watch this
for many the scraps
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
really real Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's kind of fun I try to figure out how
to put it they the it's like what you
see like Simba and all the other ones me
and the first teaser trailer wow that's
like photorealistic mmm-hmm and you know
like now you get a look at scar who I
remember being like orange with a really
defined scar yeah I'm like oh really
yeah a real jacked-up oh it's very real
you know yeah it's exactly like you
remembered all the same shots and and
minions and whatnot but just with a
sheen of yeah real rendering it's like
whoa but not that like Disney color
animated charm to it yeah now it's just
a little disturbing yeah like some
motivators like hot it's so cool look
how real it is there are ones like oh
translating it to photo realism it's
kind of a little bit disturbing yeah
yeah think about the moments that
they're not showing you in the trailer
it's like you know when he's on the
ledge and he's scars like digging into
his claws yeah he's about to throw them
off I'm like is that gonna be disturbing
now this is gonna be like really real
yeah cuz I guess it took me eight
because I was like that sounds a little
bit like chiwetel ejiofor then you see
this because like the even the scar on
him is rather subtle yeah yeah it took
me a moment to go oh there it is there
it is yeah he just looks like he's been
through the wears because I imagine that
it act it's actually gonna be kind of
scary now with them because even the
hyenas the hyenas in the animated movie
they were kinda another silly yeah dumb
villains their diamond henchman hey
they're kind of comedy relief in a way
but they all got different personalities
yeah and they're like yeah then this one
they look like creepy too they just have
a menace about mm-hmm you know there is
something about I know it's an easy
thing to complain about the
that yeah a lot of this is just like a
shot-for-shot brought to life but you
know there's there's something kind of
special to me about that is well I want
I do want to see some more of the things
that they are saying that will be new
that will be in addition to this because
they've talked about how you know like
there's things from the animated movie
you just have to keep especially because
you don't want to upset those fans and
that's what you're so beloved but
there's also gonna be new things infused
in here and at this point I'm like okay
I want to see some of those new things
infuse I do want to see that but as far
as playing to my 90s nostalgia for the
Lion King it's working on me it is
getting to me every time I see it and it
takes a little bit of like something
John you better turn off that alarm we
are this is early in the morning and we
are one taking this bad boy in the
meantime I'll tell you guys this
you guys should follow us on our patreon
page over there we do weekly Q&A a TV
show reaction stream along for many
shows that includes my hero academia did
all of attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood one punch man
supernatural awning a hill house and
Gotham and there's reaction highlights
included for several shows that includes
my hero academia supernatural one punch
man at Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
but anyway back to this right now yeah
that's what we call improv and finding a
way to fill the gap right there yeah but
yeah I mean because I know how do I put
this it's doing what the other
live-action movies did well you know how
I Beauty and the Beast still felt like
they're a cart they they feel like a
cartoon still brought to life yeah I
mean the thing about this to me that
captures my fancy and my imagination
more than a lot of their other
adaptations like this is the fact that
there is such an undertaking and
bringing this to life because this is
essentially an animated movie but that
wants to convince you this could be
photo real and it's gonna be like real
animals doing all the acting and so like
there's just a whole different
undertaking to me than just okay let's
take these
staged them and get an ensemble and you
know bring them to life whereas this is
like let's do a bunch of mocap yeah you
know kind of figure out I feel like they
have a different Liberty now to put new
things and also recreate old things in a
way that's like more impressive when you
actually recreate something and also a
little more fluid when you add something
new instead of it feeling like oh here's
the new thing you know it's like in
meeting the beast you can kind of tell
like oh here's the new stuff and here's
the classics notes and I feel like the
the blend could be nicer and I feel like
we're gonna get one more trailer perhaps
before we you know get the actual movie
because you know there's other voice
actors that you do want to hear I want
it I want to hear Seth Rogen when you
want to hear more than music
I want to hear John Oliver you know
Donald Glover Beyonce Donald Glover and
Beyonce of course you know and if you
think about it the trailer shows you the
whole movie
of course she's gonna happen now
everything's gonna happen you know that
the show is we mean the hakuna matata
MoMA and they're going through and their
montage and over those five years I
can't believe they didn't leave that a
surprise and we actually just watched
Disney nature's Penguins last night it's
just like realistic we saw that last
night so my my love for animals on a
screen right now is really honed in so
watching this and like yeah I want more
I want more of Disney animals on screen
right now I just but I do find it kind
of funny how it kind of akin to not
exactly the jungle book by Jon Favreau
but from what I saw of the Mowgli
trailer with some of the more villainous
montt not monsters villas animals here
animals Craig its nature it's the circle
of life and it moves us all but know
you've seen seen that here I was kind of
taken aback by how but by like oh when
you make them real it feels actually
kind of scary and then on the flip side
when you make some of them real
feels even more adorable Rafiki here I'm
excited I really genuinely am excited
for the said I know that Dumbo hasn't
been a big hit at the theaters lately
but that's a different kind of fan base
it's nineteen forties I don't think it
says especially with audiences now it
says beloved as Lyon so I I don't think
this feel like everything they lost with
Dumbo they're gonna regain with the line
yeah well the Lion King comes from more
recent memory and it has the benefit of
actually still being a feature-length
movie to begin with instead of needing
to be expanded by an hour yeah as some
people some people feel like oh well the
Dumbo that's part of the cool thing of
adapting it's alive but then the
opportunity of living here it's like if
they'd look like animated lions or any
of the animals just look like animated
then I would be like what's the point of
doing this but the fact that they're
bringing this to life that's what's cool
about it and shiva taja for I'm
interested to see what he does because I
know they got James Earl Jones back to
do Mufasa because he's so iconic but I
feel like so many of the voice talents
of the animated movie were iconic yeah
so team minutes likes Jeremy Irons a
scar was just a l'heure thomas gilbert
guys yes it's not Wow also coming up
cross-promotion is me but money it away
man I'm excited for this this trailer
Kate you guys more excited I think going
yeah I wonder how realistic it's gonna
look when they when they when cuz I
think that that's the moment right
wheres good towards the end were scar
and has been taking over because he
hasn't been a good leader all the
nature's destroyed yeah
we're how dark it's gonna end up looking
and getting all right he's gonna cause
global warming by himself well thank you
guys for tuning in you guys can't
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and like I said
you guys can go ahead and check us out
on our patreon page do that today people
what